[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
genetic genealogy helps id one of the
victims of the infamous green river
serial killer
even with a confession to dozens of
murders police say the case isn't closed
yet
wendy had to have her name back and they
weren't satisfied until that's done
elaine maxwell wants her charges dropped
in the latest legal bid in the jeffrey
epstein saga
plus a florida paramedic admist to
stealing vials of cobin 19 vaccines
but says he did so under duress we go
why would you do that he said well he
said there's this captain
and why police say a deadly road rage
incident was racially motivated
the defendant intentionally acted
to strike the victim with his vehicle
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
genetic genealogy identifies the
youngest victim of serial killer gary
ridgway
angenette levy spoke with a member of
the group that helped put a name to the
remains
yeah brian for decades those remains
were simply known as bones 10 but dna
technology has finally identified her
as wendy stevens for years in the 1980s
and 90s
the green river killer terrorized the
seattle area
the remains of young women and girls
left in wooded areas around the river
i was i was just a kid when this crime
really first started impacting our
community here so i've seen it both
growing up in seattle and it was seeing
the work and how it was featured here
was
one of the things that motivated me to
join the sheriff's office
kings county sheriff's office sergeant
tim meyer said the green river task
force worked tirelessly to find the
murderer
gary ridgeway was on their radar but it
wasn't until 2001 that dna testing
confirmed
ridgeway was the killer as part of a
plea agreement
he confessed to murdering 49 girls and
women
and led detectives to more remains the
work of identifying victims wasn't over
including a set known only as bones 10.
she was in our system known as bones 10
and that was just a designator that was
given
for our investigators all of our
detectives everyone at the medical
examiner's office they are not satisfied
with that
last fall investigators enlisted the
help of the dna doe project
a non-profit that uses dna from victims
to find matches to potential family
members on genealogy websites ged match
and family tree dna how quickly were you
able to
put together wendy's identity
most of the matches that we looked at
were in the third cousin range
and then when we were building them out
we found connections between those trees
and we found a couple that united
clusters of some of these matches
and that couple turned out to be wendy's
parents
bones 10 became wendy stevens a 14 year
old girl reported missing from denver
colorado in 1983
she had run away from home her remains
were found in march of 1984.
now 37 years later some answers finally
provided to wendy's family
in this case it was really difficult at
the same time there is a sense of
accomplishment being able to give her
back her name
and our other john and jane does um i
feel like it restores some of their
power and their dignity so that they can
you know um be essentially
home the dna
doe project is also working on another
green river case that's bones
20. karen binder said they had a little
bit of trouble extracting the dna
from those remains but they are working
on it and hope that they can provide
that set of bones identity and there's
also bone 17 that is another set of
remains at the kings county medical
examiner's office
right now gary ridgway he is 71 years
old and he is in a prison in washington
state
cerney serving 49 life sentences brian
angelina is there any way the public can
help with these cases
yeah there really are a couple of things
that the public can do this is an
all volunteer non-profit organization so
people can donate to it and all of that
money i'm told goes to dna testing which
as you know can be very expensive
and gen match that's one of the websites
i am told by karen binder that
you have to opt in to allow law
enforcement to look at your profile
in these cases so they are asking that
people do that if they submit their dna
to those websites thank you and jeanette
and joining us now for legal analysis is
criminal defense attorney julie
rundleman
along with terry austin julie this is
about giving
jane doe or as they called her bones 10
a person that many had long forgotten
her name as a former prosecutor you know
how important it is
for the victim's family to get that
closure what are your thoughts
yeah you know when i listened to
antoinette talking about the idea that
someone
especially a 14 year old is identified
by just the word bones ten it's
absolutely chilling
and just imagine a family who loses a 14
year old which by the way
i believe the 14 year old was the
youngest at least
as far as we know the youngest victim
of this serial killer and so it's
imperative obviously there's never going
to be closure for this family
um but for all these years they've
wondered is it their child
that was the victim and now at least
they know
and it's not just important for the name
um they'll never be closure but at least
they know that there are at least some
answers in regards to where their child
is
exactly and those answers are huge for
the family terry ridgway was convicted
interestingly enough
without naming or iding some of his
victims what do you think this means
finally for the family to know
where their daughter went and to hear
her name
well like julie said i think it does
give them some closure remember
wendy ran away from home and they didn't
know what happened to her so on the one
hand
they now know on the other hand you know
they could have been thinking that maybe
she just was leading another life so
it's got to be
extremely disappointing i will say i was
impressed by dr catherine taylor she was
the forensic
anthropologist on the case and she just
kept at it
and she said one of the reasons she kept
at it was because
this was one of the youngest victims she
was only 14 years old
and the anthropologists wanted to make
sure that the family knew exactly what
happened to their daughter
and absolutely going to applaud the
perseverance of those who worked on this
case
not letting almost four decades go by
without them finding a name for that
victim thank you both
still ahead on law and crime daily the
shocking admission of the acting capital
police chief
over the deadly riots but first actress
lori lockland is out of jail for her
role in the college admission scandal
while her husband finds himself still
behind bars next
welcome back and now to check in on some
of today's top stories
fashion designer and husband of full
house actress laurie lachlan
massimo gianouli has once again been
denied early release
a federal judge ruled that his case does
not meet the extraordinary circumstances
required for home confinement
gia nulli is currently serving a
five-month sentence in california for
his role in the college admissions
scandal
gia newly's attorney said he had been in
isolation for nearly two months
which has apparently taken a toll on the
designer's mental
physical and emotional well-being
giannuli is due to be released
in april the acting capital police chief
admitted to failure's inculpability in
her department's response to the deadly
insurrection
chief yoganata pittman said they were
aware at least two days prior
there was a strong potential for
violence but did not sufficiently act
the statement was made to a house
committee in a closed door meeting
she said capitol police requested
assistance from the national guard on
january 6
but had to wait over an hour five people
died during the storming of the building
including capitol police officer brian
siknik
attorneys for gillane maxwell are asking
a federal judge in new york to dismiss
all charges against her maxwell is
accused of sex trafficking and
recruiting girls on behalf of now
deceased
millionaire pedophile jeffrey epstein in
the motion to dismiss
maxwell claims a non-prosecution
agreement or npa
between epstein and the federal
government in 2007 should shield her as
well
in addition defense attorneys say the
charges are not specific
and that prosecutors unfairly use the
grand jury in white plains new york
rather than in manhattan where she's
charged maxwell pled not guilty and her
trial is scheduled to begin in july
prosecutors say maxwell helped epstein
exploit girls as young as 14 years old
maxwell played a critical role in
helping epstein to identify
friend and groom minor victims for abuse
in some cases maxwell participated in
the abuse
herself that abuse included
sexualized massages during which the
minor
victim was fully or partially nude
the sexualized massages developed into
sexual encounters
for which maxwell in some instances was
present
and participated maxwell and epstein
worked together
to entice these minor victims to travel
to epstein's residences
here for legal analysis is criminal
defense attorney julie rendellman and
co-host terry austin
terry prosecutors vagueness of when and
who
really seemed to be the driving force
here in the defense's motions
but is that a reason to to dismiss the
charges
well yes it is a reason to dismiss it
but if in fact it was
dismissed for vagueness they would be
able to
replete because it would be dismissed
without prejudice and
i actually took a look at the charges
and the pleadings and frankly i think
they
are specific enough they don't have the
minutia
and the day-to-day detail but they do
say that the crimes occurred
between 94 and 97 and they do give some
specificity so
i don't think it will be dismissed at
the end of the day
agreed julie the defense is trying
everything to make these charges go away
what do you make of their argument that
epstein's npa in florida should also
protect maxwell in federal court
since uh maxwell was arrested and the
problem she has with it is twofold
one um the you know the agreement not to
prosecute
wasn't with her it was with epstein but
the biggest problem is it wasn't just
not with her it was in florida
florida has no control over what the new
york
government decides to do or what the
federal government decides to do
so i don't know how she would survive an
argument
where it's florida that made this
quote-unquote agreement
that has absolutely nothing to do with
the federal charges in new york
yeah it's been interesting to see how
that plays out terry quickly what do you
think about that agreement as well
should it protect elaine maxwell it does
seem as julie's saying is
kind of apples and oranges yeah i don't
think it's going to protect her here i
think different jurisdictions and i
think it doesn't relate to her
and it was not her agreement so i think
she's going to have a hard
you know road road there and we'll be
able to watch every step of that road as
to continue thank you both
for contributing on that story coming up
on law and crime daily houston police
officers accused
of being on the other side of the law
plus
find out how a florida man went from
paramedic of the year
to behind bars those cases and more
after the break
[Music]
now to florida where police say the 2020
paramedic of the year
and a fire captain are behind missing
vials of cobit 19 vaccines
joshua colon is facing charges of
forgery and falsifying medical records
cologne was assigned to administer
vaccines to first responders
according to the polk county sheriff's
office colon claims fire captain anthony
demano
pressured him into leaving extra doses
for his family
colon has resigned from his position
captain d'amato remains an employee on
good standing
but sheriff grady judd says that will
soon change
he's under criminal investigation he
would be arrested today
but he's on his way back from out west
he will be arrested upon his rival here
there's a captain at the fire department
called
tony de yamano
and tony supposedly went to joshua
cologne
and said you know i'd like some vaccine
for my mother and joshua colon
said rebuffed him said no i can't do
that
so he made several requests of this
vaccine
from the paramedic and the captain was
told i can't do that
so what occurred was there were three
syringes
with three doses of the vaccine
that joshua colombe put in a plastic bag
put in a special refrigerator and sealed
it
and then at the direction of the captain
he took a break
so he left take a break and when he came
back voila the seal's broken
and the vaccinations are gone
back for analysis is julie rendleman and
terry austin
julie this whole duress thing doesn't
really sound right to me as i understand
it duress is when you are compelled
by danger or emergency i didn't hear it
here did you
yeah i didn't just so we're clear brian
this is so bad and so wrong
i mean we talk about the fact that you
know people are
somewhat described as the hunger games
where people are trying desperately
to get um access to vaccine
and now we have someone doing what
they're doing which is just so
despicable
but you're right i don't see the dress
here yes there might be some mitigation
in the fact that the captain may have
held something over his head even if we
believe that's true which i question
whether it's true or not
um but no i don't think at the end of
the day the duress in terms of an
actual defense claim will work and help
him
out of the situation all right so terry
maybe no defense but the way they're
getting arrested in the treatment
they're receiving kind of bothers me a
little
because you have one of them uh who gets
to resign
as a first responder and another who
gets to leisurely drive across the
country in his
rv to get arrested on his time
how was that working when they stole
from first responders who are attempting
to stay healthy to help their community
you know you're 100 correct as is julie
this is a despicable crime
and you know that is what the fire
department is doing that has to do with
his misconduct but rest assured
polk county sheriff grady is going to
make sure that they have criminal
charges against them
and those charges include forgery and it
includes
falsifying medical records and you know
creating a fictional person i mean i
love this
sheriff we've seen him before one of the
things that he said that i thought was
so interesting he said
do these guys have brain cells and
what he said is they not only stole
these vaccines
but they put them in a car so it
wouldn't even be
usable for the purpose that they stole
it for so
i think that they're going to be
prosecuted yeah not the sharpest tool in
the sheds but glad that they were
discovered
in this case thank you both for the your
comments when we come back
a road rage incident that ends in murder
was it racially motivated
a grand jury in texas has indicted nine
houston police officers
after a deadly raid led to investigators
uncovering an alleged scheme to steal
overtime money
dennis tuttle regina nicholas and their
dog were shot to death in their
home during a raid
executed by squad 15 of the houston
police department
narcotics division the investigation
determined first that goings lied to a
judge to obtain a no-knock
warrant to raid the tuttle's
home on harding street and that officers
had been
involved on that squad in a long-term
scheme
to steal overtime money from the city of
houston
one officer was indicted for murder and
faces up to life in prison
the other eight officers are charged
with engaging in organized criminal
activity
theft by a public servant and tampering
with governmental records
several other officers were charged last
year four officers were shot during the
raid
leaving one paralyzed a massachusetts
man is accused of murder following a
deadly road rage incident that
investigators say was racially motivated
dean capsalis is being held without bail
after belmont police say he yelled
racial slurs and hit a man with his
truck
henry tapia died from his injuries not
long after the incident
witnesses say the two were seen pulling
over to the side of the road
and getting into an angry dispute mr
tapia had been involved in a verbal
altercation
on upland road when an individual
had yelled racial slurs at mr tapia
who was a was a black man and then
at after that that slurring and the use
of those
terms came as the verbal altercation
seemed to have come to an
end in fact mr tapia was observed by
various witnesses
on the sidewalk and in their home to be
returning to his call
when the slurs were used at that point
the individual
who was later identified as dean
capsalis
allegedly entered his vehicle which was
a dodge dakota pickup
drove it at mr tapia striking him as he
stood by
the driver's side of his car
mr tapia was dragged a short distance
by that pickup truck before it fled the
scene
police ordered a be on the lookout for
the red truck and the defendant turned
himself in
about 30 minutes later
those are the facts they do not speak
to the loss of life partner
and father suffered by mr tapia's family
we are reminded that incidents like this
that are allegedly born of hateful
speech
have a lasting impact on families
friends and our neighbors here in this
community
back one last time for analysis is julie
rendellman and terry austin
julie at the bail hearing the defense
said kapalas
owns a business in the community and is
a father when asking for bail the judge
denied that request
and held him without bail do you think
that was the right move by the judge
so i i think both you and i brian know
that if this case had happened
in brooklyn or new york i would say 99
of the murder cases are on remand so
there's no battle so it's not unusual
for us to see that
i think one of the biggest problems for
this defendant is not only did he
run over the victim or at least
allegedly do that
but he fled the scene so there could be
no clear indication of an individual
not wanting to come to court then
fleeing the scene now some would say he
turned himself in later
but still he fled the scene after
committing this crime and i think that's
one of the things besides
some other you know problems in his
background that the judge is going to
look at uh when thinking
he's not going to come to court on his
own yeah and that's the ultimate
question when it comes to bail you look
at their history you look at what the
strength of the case and like you said
julie the flight is a big part
terry a hit and run with racial epithets
does that amount to a hate crime
or civil rights charges both actually
brian because
the massachusetts attorney general can
bring charges
under their civil rights act and also
under their
hate crime laws so in addition to the
murder charges that
we might see against caps alice we will
see
i think some civil rights charges and
some
hate crime charges because there were
words that were said
at the scene of the crime and others
heard these words so
i definitely think obviously the road
rage in and of itself is a horrible
crime
but when you think about the fact that
underneath all of that
it was based on a bias and the whole
purpose of the hate crime law
is to make sure that you don't have
these sort of
bias motivated crimes so i do think
we're going to see those types of
charges
and hopefully they'll be successful as
far as that's concerned
the only positive part of this case and
yes he
ran away was the fact that uh he did
ultimately turn himself in
all right thank you for joining us here
at long crime daily we'll see you next
time we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you